la parole est à joël billard pour le
groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur le ministre à la suite de votre
décret concernant les rythmes scolaires
l'inquiétude et la colère des élus des
enseignants et des parents d'élèves ne
s'apaise pas il est évident que proposer
une réforme de ce genre au niveau
national pouvant s'adapter à la fois à
une école isolée dans les zones rurales
et à un groupe scolaire implanté dans
une grande ville est tout simplement
irréaliste
un cannes national ne peut donc se
concevoir sans dérogation tenant compte
des contraintes locales et bien entendu
de la spécificité des territoires ruraux
comme par exemple faire venir une heure
par jour une personne diplômée pour
encadrer les enfants à moins de mettre
en place une garderie ce qui ne
correspond pas à l'esprit du décret et
bien sûr sans oublier l'organisation et
le coût des transports
raison pour laquelle le groupe ump a
déposé à l'initiative de son président
une proposition de loi qui permet à
chaque commune de s'organiser comme elle
le souhaite afin de proposer aux enfants
et aux familles l'organisation la plus
favorable
il semblerait que votre réforme ne
permettent pas d'agir positivement sur
les rythmes biologiques de l'enfant
pourtant pourtant à la base du débat par
ailleurs si on en croit les expériences
passées les aménagements des rythmes
scolaires serait sans incidence sur le
résultat des élèves
comme il est facile de le constater
cette nouvelle organisation est
techniquement très difficilement
réalisable et financièrement
inacceptable d'autant plus que les
communes doivent faire face sur trois
ans à une baisse de leur notation de
fonctionnement à titre d'exemple pour ma
commune cela représente environ 10
points de fiscalité
compte tenu du ras-le-bol fiscale cette
nouvelle imposition n'est pas
envisageable
monsieur le ministre j'ai adressé une
note à tous les maires de mon
département en ce sens à savoir de
demander au gouvernement de renoncer à
ce décret ou de laisser aux communes le
libre choix de l'organisation du temps
scolaire et de garantir à celle ci la
compensation intégrale des charges
monsieur le ministre je me suis toujours
posé en défenseur de la ruralité et
aujourd'hui je continue à essayer
d'aider mes collègues maires qui se
débattent devant les multiples
difficultés rencontrées monsieur le
ministre écouter les voix qui montent de
cette france profonde et donnez-leur
aujourd'hui la réponse qu'ils attendent
merci la parole à vincent peillon
ministre de l'éducation nationale et le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur d'abord
il ya beaucoup d'éléments dans votre
question le premier élément si vraiment
les rythmes scolaires n'avait aucune
incidence sur les résultats scolaires je
ne m'expliquerai pas que les groupes
parlementaires y compris ump et mon
collègue luc chatel ait fait une si
longue consultation qui arrivait à la
conclusion unanime comme l'académie de
médecine comme tous les pédopsychiatres
comme quoi il n'est pas légitime que la
france d'ailleurs vous avez bénéficié
vous dans votre jeunesse de cinq
matinées de classe soit le seul pays du
monde à n'avoir depuis 2008 que quatre
demi journées et cela a des conséquences
vous l'avez vu encore récemment sur le
niveau scolaire et donc vous ne pouvez
pas considérer à moins d'avoir
totalement changé d'avis mais ce serait
étonnant qu'en l'espace de deux ans ce
qui est établi par tout le monde ce qui
avait été porté par vous même lorsque
vous étiez aux responsabilités à savoir
de nouveau rythme scolaire soit bon pour
l'apprentissage maintenant sur la
question que vous soulevez c'est la même
il y a deux choses qu'il ne faut pas
confondre il y à notre constitution il
ya le code de l'éducation qui fait que
l'éducation est un service public
national et il revient à l'état de fixer
le temps scolaire et heureusement le
temps scolaire est fixé par l'état et de
ce point de vue là l'organisation du
temps scolaire ç'a toujours été le cas
d'ailleurs quand on est revenu à aux
quatre jours en 2008 il n'y a même pas
eu les consultations que j'ai organisé
dans l'autre sens il est décidé par
l'état par contre pour la première fois
et c'est sans doute ce qui pose un
certain nombre de problèmes dans
l'histoire des relations entre l'école
et les collectivités nous avons souhaité
et c'est ce que nous jean pour le
passage aux 4 jours et demi demander
l'avis des maires les impliquer dans ce
qu'on appelle la coéducation pour
construire non seulement le temps
scolaire mais le temps périscolaire mais
sur ce temps périscolaire vous est
absolument libre aujourd'hui comme hier
il n'y a aucune contrainte le temps
scolaire c'est l'éducation nationale et
donc il y aura cours le mercredi matin
car c'est l'école qu'il assume ce qui
est après la classe et le temps scolaire
obligatoire revient aux collectivités
locales aujourd'hui comme hier et là
vous aurez les uns et les autres à
prendre vos responsabilités
il ya une nouveauté effectivement vous
avez raison il y à une nouveauté c'est
que pour la première fois l'état mais un
certain nombre de financements comme la
caisse d'allocations familiales pour
vous permettre de mieux le faire et je
serais intéressé à savoir ce que vous
faisiez à bord l'association des maires
de france et le président de
l'association des maires ruraux la met
en place chez lui et l'association des
maires de france qui est présidée par
l'ump a pu montrer que 80 % des mères
qui était passée on était satisfait et
que ça se passe mieux dans le rural
qu'ailleurs et donc de ce point de vue
là n'hésitez pas à consulter vos
collègues ils vous montreront comment
ils font pour leur s il ya peut-être une
certaine part de mauvaise volonté
peut-être pas finalement un intérêt pour
les élèves et les enfants à la hauteur
des exigences de l'autre pays mais vous
l'aviez prouver aussi quand vous étiez
aux responsabilités où vous n'avez rien
fait pour l'école de la république si ce
n'est pour la détruire progressivement
mercy mercy nous en avons le chers
collègues nous en avons fini avec les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement je
vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15 pour l'examen de la paix